c'est l'une des annonces du président
Macron hier soir en interview sur France
2 elle les TP et PME qui consomment
beaucoup d'énergie vont pouvoir
bénéficier du bouclier tarifaire à 15%
pour les prix du gaz et de l'électricité
une mesure qui doit entrer en vigueur au
premier janvier prochain une bouffée
d'oxygène pour les petits patrons comme
le gérant de cette boulangerie de Tours
Nord rencontré par Florent Clavel toutes
les armoires de congélation de stockage
congélation positif et négatif donc ça
c'est déjà un gros consommateur
d'énergie chez ce boulanger
l'électricité c'est comme la farine
indispensable 90% du matériel électrique
seul le four à une partie gaz mais le
résultat est le même une hausse
astronomique de la facture d'énergie ça
complètement explosé le gaz a été
multiplié par 3
donc on va se retrouver avec des
factures de 1200 1300 et des régulations
c'est pas jusqu'où ça